last question today hey David we hear a
lot about black Americans voting for
Democrats and Trump claiming that he has
more black support than any Republican
in history what are some demographic
groups that you think might move support
from one party to another well I'll tell
you one that's not going to be moving
support from one party to another
anytime soon
that's Jews I know that there are sort
of some notable individual Jewish
Americans who support Republicans but
Jews are an overwhelmingly liberal group
they with the exception of of like the
very Orthodox Hasidic Jews in Summit
parts of the u.s. who do tend to vote
more more Republican than other Jews
Jews were one of the biggest supporting
groups of Barack Obama both times and so
if that's not a group that's gonna shift
anytime soon
obviously African Americans are being
mentioned black Americans they are not
going to be shifting support to
Republicans any time soon not because as
we hear from some on the right blacks
are quote on the plantation or have been
assumed as supporters by the Democratic
Party it's because genuinely the
policies of Republicans are bad for
black Americans and for Latino Americans
and for all sorts of groups so I don't
expect that to change in the Republican
Party and therefore I don't expect black
Americans to start supporting
Republicans in great numbers a more
interesting one that actually has some
potential to shift is what about
working-class Midwestern white voters
will they move more towards Democrats as
Donald Trump continues to crush them
with his policies trade policy the tax
cut which is not even really a cut for
many of these middle-class Midwestern
white Americans will they be interested
when we think about 2020 and this is why
the earlier question about the right
choice for Democrats for 2020 would a
Midwestern or southern Democrat who
speaks to that
middle-class Midwestern white portion of
the electorate be a better choice than
like a northeastern liberal to run on
the Democratic side I actually don't
think that matters so much as long as
they are able to speak to and engage
with the working-class Midwestern white
voters in the way Trump was able to
despite the fact that his policies are a
disaster for them and then another one
that I'm interested in is what about
second and third-generation Latino
voters and what I mean by that is you
have so two backup
Latino voters are overwhelmingly liberal
other than Cubans
okay so Cubans with this very
anti-communist anti-castro mentality
when they come to the United States they
are sort of like the primary subgroup of
Latino voters in terms of country of
origin that does tend to vote more for
Republicans although even that may
change and we may we may see that change
so are the non Cuban Latinos going to
maybe move a little bit towards
Republicans as they get older in the
United States and acquire wealth and
have children here and I don't know the
answer of in the short term with the
Republican policies that we're seeing
coming out of trumps administration the
answer is definitely not but bigger
picture I actually think that it's more
likely that Cubans go left
then other latinos go right one other
thought would be what about if you look
at high cost of living areas which tend
to be blue areas right but not always
high cost of living areas that are
outside of cities so not the city so so
like Orange County in California is an
example of a high cost of living area
that actually has been relatively
conservative historically sort of
appealing to low tax Mitt Romney type
Republicans rather than social
conservatives will they start moving to
the left if they continue to see sort of
this unhinged trumpian ISM that is not
the Mitt Romney republicanism that they
are sort of in in favor of
will they start to move towards
Democrats and in fact the midterms in
Orange County showed us that not only is
it possible but it did happen in that
particular Enclave those are a few of my
thoughts what groups am I missing what
groups might we see what demographic
groups might we see shift either left to
right or right to left over the next few
election cycle send me your thoughts
we've got a great bonus show for you
today I'm at a time
trust me it's a good one become a member
become a patron get instant access to
the bonus show